good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hey jax
how you doing i'm doing good on this
tuesday not as good as i was a dern
yesterday because
isn't here and it was just so special
all day yesterday i was just riding this
high
of you know brew in the studio relishing
in like all the positive energy yeah and
just like really feeling proud of my boy
you know so today we have no brew no do
that's surprising mom's busy mom's busy
okay oh yeah you're going places after
this so we miss our boys really weed and
boys and we making noise yeah so other
than that i'm doing really well
yesterday was a very busy but productive
day for moi
and
can't complain me neither i mean i i
could but i won't i mean i could because
it's still like it's a scorcher again
i'm wearing shorts but it's freezing in
the studio so i'm wearing a blanket so i
look like a schlub like you just can't
win in august
you can't there's no winning in august
except
the song august that's the only saving
grace have you even listened to it in
august of course i i just even feel like
it's not even the vibe by the way i
totally listened to the first
go-around of reverie yesterday because
margot texted me i don't know if she
listened to the toast because she
definitely didn't but she was like i'm
begging you like you need to sit with
this album and i'm like okay so i was
reading a book and i put it on the
background and i honestly missed the
whole thing because i was like in the
book you know yeah no that reading and
listening to music sounds like a good
idea but it's really not unless it's an
album you've already lived with like
honestly i think evermore is the perfect
reading album to listen to yeah but it
just gets
the lines get crossed you know so i
finished
people we meet on vacation yesterday and
like you really didn't like it so i was
like i know i'm not going to like it
because we have a very similar taste and
you're always recommending books to me
and i actually like enjoyed it it was
fine it was like nothing crazy it wasn't
great i don't think i'll continue taking
book recommendations from tiktok because
people like we're hyping this book up
like it was the last book on earth and
even though it was really sweet there
were moments i laughed and i was
involved
i couldn't tell you what the point of
the book was like literally it was just
like a love like it i don't want to
spoil it but like literally nothing
happened yeah and so it was really long
and i was like okay waiting for the
twist or waiting for something to happen
and there's this whole thing like we
don't talk about what happened on our
trip in croatia we don't talk about what
happened and then at the end you find
out what happened on their trip in
croatia and you really feel like you
wasted six hours of your life like
you're like this is what it's about
still unclear why the book is called
people we mean on vacation irrelevant to
the subject matter somebody told me that
the column she writes at her magazine is
called people we meet on vacation and if
that's true i missed that whole fact and
they they missed that yeah um
so i don't really
like i just can't tell you
what your plane of the book is you're
like the book wasn't that bad i kind of
enjoyed it i laughed here and there and
i'm like i really didn't like the book i
wouldn't recommend it blah blah blah but
we both have the same reason no we both
gave it the same rating which is a three
yeah i gave it a three i rated it a
three and you rated three so like
we just i guess our rating scales mean
different things yeah cause if
something's really bad you're gonna give
it a three well yeah this is my scale
one means i didn't finish it and i
wouldn't even rate a book of one i
wouldn't write a book that i didn't
finish
two means i finished this book and it
pained me every step of the way i really
didn't want to finish it i just really
got through it just to see what happened
and didn't even make up for the time i
spent on it
rarely happens three
not great not bad i read the book
had moments of enjoyment but not great
four really really good enjoyed my time
with this book five will be telling all
of my friends and family everyone has to
read this book i never wanted it to end
good times okay so mine is not that
similar i don't have ones or twos either
because like there are plenty of books
we were liars i started that probably
would have been one but i didn't finish
it so i don't grade it so i really start
with three and i don't have many threes
threes is like this book sucks but it
was finishable yeah finishable so now
that i think about it's like one very
bad too bad three meh four good five
very good okay so
for me
three is like not great but finishable
four is
like so so so so good but like not like
missing one little thing you know
because then when i compare it to my
five star books like i remember my i
feel like i've read a lot of four star
books and i don't even remember them
they were just like fun times but then
there are books that stick with you
forever like evelyn hugo um lucky's girl
luckiest girl alive if
we were the one what's it called if we
before we were strangers no colleen it
ends with us
um so there's a few that like stick with
you forever and those are the five stars
but for the most part like the books i
read and i like are fours
yeah same okay so we have the pretty
much the same same scale so i just feel
like nobody really needs to read
people we meet people mean on vacation
because first of all
she didn't meet anyone on vacation like
can't stress that enough they're the
opposite no they met in college
and two um it was just really long and
pointless
but it was like a she i liked her
writing style like did you read beatride
by the same author no but i've heard
that i need to but now i'm feeling
discouraged it's good okay and it's so
much better i i read it last summer i
really liked it which is why i even read
people we meet on vacation okay which i
feel like which is why people loved
beach read people who mean on vacation
was like very you know highly
anticipated yeah i feel like it's the
same thing for malibu rising
no because taylor jenkins read is like
has this whole world going on and she's
like built i'm sorry did she write daisy
jones yeah
hated that book oh i liked it but i
understand why you didn't um so that's
the book news that's the book news i'm
still reading my book rules of civility
which i'm really enjoying and i wanted
to recommend another book to you oh but
also we have to talk about the morgan
library the morgan library i got a dm
from them too oh my god they reached out
to me and i guess claudia too like
saying if we wanted to come come through
like they'd love to set up like a tour
we've gotta go they didn't say like
anything about a tour to me they were my
message was a little longer than yours
oh interesting what were they offering
um i didn't read it because i just saw
it i don't know if we get to touch the
morrigan ladders no similar didn't allow
it no no no i think that's forbidden no
but i would love you know a private tour
um but we should definitely go totally
okay cool we'll send the photos i'm so
like every time i get a dm from someone
like or something so exciting no no
that's like just like oh my god i'm so
excited i screenshotted i sent it to my
family and then i forgot to respond
totally every single time everything i
haven't responded to morgan library even
though like why wouldn't i not the
morgan library nothing wearing ladders
oh that sucks okay yeah we need to
respond um but the other thing i wanted
to say the morgan library oh did you
watch bathroom paradise i did i didn't
and i just feel so even reading that not
great book was better than watching that
show so i watched it i didn't mind last
night's episode but at the end of the
episode it became clear to me that it's
perhaps going to be my that was my last
episode that i watched i'll give a
little review and actually the drama of
the episode like it was actually pretty
dramatic dramatic there was some tea and
[ __ ] but then like that was buttoned up
um my favorite person went home
and
next week's ep i mean sorry tonight's
episode again yeah it's monday and
tuesday tonight's episode like it looks
like drama the boys are like fighting
he's running through the sand
i
there was not one element of like
tomorrow night that looked interesting
to me at all so
i
and also also i mean i'll wait till the
recap but as a rose ceremony there was
only one person
who it was like unclear who his rose was
going to go to everyone else like looks
like they're about to get engaged wow so
i just feel like it's all kind of done
totally you know what i mean and like
new guys are coming in and there's gonna
be drama because like if someone invites
you on a date even if you're vibing with
someone else like you go on that date
and if it's like a beautiful sunset
horseback riding moment like you kiss on
that date and it's not a big deal then
you go home and you if you like the
other person better then you go back to
your person so i just feel like
everybody's gonna wind up with the same
people i swear all these people are
gonna get engaged fabulous yeah so i
just like felt like
the show was over well you'll have to
explain to me like what happened because
uh i just i couldn't do it i will
explain to you what happened because i
think you'll actually be interested in
this particular drama and that'll be in
the tv recap segment yes but i guess
without further ado to do where are you
not here as we discussed um very
tragically actually that neither do nor
brew could attend today
moment of silence for the ooze just move
on with the show i can't because once i
start thinking about these precious men
all right then i'll do it
okay
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
wow that felt good okay pretty good i
didn't know if you had it in you
today's episode is brought to you by
hydro jug hydration made easy
so there's so many benefits of drinking
water um i'm famously known for having a
really hard time drinking water but
whenever i do i feel like i have
improved energy it can curb your
appetite it gives mental clarity it
gives you clear skin and just overall
wellness but over 75 of americans are
dehydrated and water is crucial to your
health every cell and tissue inside your
body requires water to function and not
just any amount of water but a gallon a
day could really make a huge impact on
your overall health so enter the hydro
drug which is a fabulous water bottle
that will help you stay on track
drinking as much water as you can per
day it holds a half a gallon of water it
is a leak-proof seal leak-proof seal
excuse me the mouth is very wide in the
opening it has a carry loop an
integrated handle a measurement scale
it's also bpa free and dishwasher safe
so it's shatter proof and it comes with
a sleeve that insulates your water and
it protects your hydra drug the sleeve
so it has two pockets also we could
throw your phone in there it's like a
purse you know you throw your keys in
there it's fabulous and it really just
does keep you on track and i feel like
when i'm in that you know
a good way like wave of drinking a lot
of water like it really does oh my god
the benefits are you know it's secure to
life
water is the key to life and i love the
hydro jug because one it's the perfect
size of water bottle you're getting so
much water if you drink the whole thing
in a day like you're in a really good
spot but you can still carry it around
with you and you know if you're out all
day like you need to be drinking water
all day so it's perfect it comes in the
cutest colors there's like a color for
everyone i have a purple one and a pink
one and i love it so much and it also
kind of like gamifies drinking water
it's like am i gonna hit my goal for the
day and it's really just a fun way to
drink more water which everyone should
because it's literally like will
literally solve your problems clear your
acne and
allegedly pay your bills you can check
hydra jug out at the hydrodrug.com and
use the discount code toast to get 10
off your order today the hype is real
hydro drugs are changing the game for
anyone on the go so that's code toast at
the hydro jug.com to get that 10 off
today and start hydrating in style enjoy
you guys start hydrating
you too must see i know i'm honest
okay first story some exciting music
news casey musgraves announces her new
album and film star-crossed she shared
her new song as well as a lethal trailer
for the album visual albums it's like a
movie it's like no it seemed like
different music videos for different
songs it said album and
film
i don't know i don't know what it is i
don't know what it is but average
fashion vlogger is in it and that just
made my day and the girl we were
literally talking about yesterday from
hacks the assistant meg stalter salter i
think her name is oh oh the assistant
yeah not the not the no not the girl
okay except
what's her name right yeah no the
assistant who we were just talking about
i told you she's like an internet like
thing got it i didn't even see her
because i was just like so happy for
corny me too also we need to talk about
the song yeah the visuals that we're
seeing and then of course like the corny
of it all let's start positive okay the
visuals are stunning she has a very
unique aesthetic it's very dime store
cowgirl rhinestone cowboy like it's
it's so unique and it's so her and i
really trust her vision when it comes to
like aesthetics and outfits and it's the
church and the rodeo like it's great
but i did listen to the song
star-crossed and it's
not my vibe
okay i like the song i obviously it's
not a bop i do think it's like the
perfect and it's also like not very long
it feels like sort of a prelude to the
album so i feel like and it's very even
specific like yesterday i signed the
papers i gave you your name back you
moved out of the house it's like you
know there's no having to read between
the lines here totally and i feel like
she's setting us up for this era i feel
like it's more so like um
maybe like an educational briefer than
like i'm listening to this on the radio
even though i found it to be like a very
beautiful song but
again like not a bop it's not going to
be like blasting through your speakers
but i just felt it was it felt like a
prelude to an album yeah i guess the
thing for me is that
i take a lot of pride in being like a
day one casey musgrave stan and i know
in this family we have uh you know we
we disagree about like who invented but
like i know for 100 facts like i
invented casey muskraves in this family
and i feel very protective over her and
i think the reason why i initially
connected with her was obviously i love
country music and she had her own spin
on country and it was so
like every lyric was so poignant and it
was just so great and so different and
so like never been done and then with
her most recent album it really wasn't
even that country but it was
i was so on board with it and i loved it
and i just feel like she's just getting
further and further away
from that initial thing that i loved
about her and of course she doesn't have
to stay that because of me and people
evolve and her styles evolve but i just
was really drawn to that and this just
is so different that i'm struggling
yeah she's definitely leaning more into
you know the alternative space oh yeah
because that and i think that's really
who she is
she's also a dinosaur cowgirl and so
that will always be like a part of her
and her music but
she's kind ev with every album she's
like
modernizing more and more i i think she
has a great sound no matter what she's
doing and i just i think she's so
talented that it's just
interesting to see what she wants to do
next you know i understand she's a very
very nice like it's not same trailer
different part like no it's not days are
over no and her first three albums were
literally like just extensions of one
another like same trailer different park
which was
so
beautiful then um pageant material
and then she made a christmas album
right so maybe it was just the first two
albums that were like very much a
continuation of one another like any of
the songs were really like
interchangeable um and i just loved that
sound and i feel like i evolved with her
through golden hour and golden hour is
a miracle it's
it's so stunning so i do trust her
vision i'm sure i'll end up liking it
but it just feels like a lot of change
you know me i'm a creature of habit like
i
it's hard
i understand it doesn't feel like that
much change it feels like a neck a
natural next step but
if you're waiting for diamonds for
coward girl yeah i can imagine how it's
like no i'm jerry stark i think for like
i'm not saying that this is you but like
for bandwagon people who learned about
casey from golden hour i'm not saying
i'm not saying this is you okay like for
people who learned about casey through
golden hour because it was so successful
and then one album of the year and she
just like became so famous in that time
this probably feels like you know of
course but they don't know the reason
how did you explain my pov i've been
there since you're an open-minded person
thank you i'm admittedly not like i'm if
something changed like i've actually
only recently discovered that i am in
the definition of a creature of habit
like i order the same thing in for
dinner every night i have the same like
four meals in rotation i really never
cut my hair or do anything crazy i use
the same makeup every day i wear the
same like i really am
very change averse and i think that
applies to my music as well i'm learning
so much about myself
understood well if you think about it
from casey's point of view she put out
dimes for cowgirl pageant material i'm
sure she put her heart and soul into
those albums like her nana's voicemail's
on in everything literally and like it
was just pretty much wholly ignored and
then she puts out golden hour and it's
like has this new sound this new vibe
and it's the toast of the town so like
why wouldn't you do that again because
it's just you know what it's this
culture of people pretending that
country music isn't good and i'm so sick
of it
and you know what if you are a casey
stan and you don't know songs from same
trailer different park or pageant
material you my friend are fraudulent
yeah that's right fraudulent and i
implore you to go do some research okay
educate yourself
do better
okay well
this is what we have i'm excited i don't
want to be negative i'm embracing it i'm
just i'm having a hard time with change
i know but like what in what world did
you expect what was coming next to sound
like the first album no i knew we knew
it was going to be more golden than
golden hour 100
i knew that
i knew that and you know
i knew it
but you're still disappointed
i'm not disappointed at all i didn't
like that song but not gonna like every
song someone releases like
it's just
i'm i'm nervous okay i'm conflict
diverse i'm a creature of habit let's
talk about even more positives which is
like obviously the aesthetics of the
video like look so sickening can't wait
for all of that average fashion blogger
makes a cameo as like some sort of
bridezilla which was just such a treat
for the viewers i literally
screenshotted it and i send it to you
guys because she's like in this like
insane like
gar like hair style garb and i'm like
is this corny and you guys were like i
think so i'm like no no i think it's
corny and it is honestly okay so you
sent that and i was like what's that
from and you said new jaycee and i
assumed
and i assumed that it was um
like jc was like a tick tock like star
or something that i just totally missed
or whatever and then like an hour later
an hour later i like went to listen to
the new casey and watch the video and i
saw her i'm like oh this [ __ ] meant new
casey i really have such i cannot type
it's so bad and i think i've only
recently learned it because we've been
doing so much like text messaging
about important things like ever since
we launched spritz which by the way code
toast
is 20 off and today's the last day
because then tomorrow it goes to 10 for
like the rest of our lives so 20 off the
variety pack code toast society.com
toast i meant to tell you guys that
yesterday i'm sorry today's the last day
that the code is 20 so get your variety
packs like enjoy them this weekend
second class weekend of summer they'll
ship really fast yeah okay so what i was
saying was like we've been texting so
much in all these group chats with our
agencies and like i've been realizing
like the way you type is not okay like
with you guys i'm always just like
asterisk asterisk like claudia sends a
text and then we're like and now for the
english version
i cannot type and i've been doing
diction a lot but also like she [ __ ]
with me too like
so i actually didn't even realize i said
jason yeah and i didn't even question it
i was like oh i'm just old and jc is
like this new popping person on tickets
average fashion blogger and then i
was ready to watch a video for myself
and i was like oh new casey yeah sorry
about that that's totally my fault
because like that's why i didn't have a
reaction in the chat because i was like
i guess i just don't know jay-z oh my
god that's but i'm happy for courtney
by the way she's so funny i just like
love when people who are nice and
talented like get what they deserve 100
she's so the real deal she's if you
don't if you're the one person out there
who doesn't follow her like treat
yourself treat yourself she's just so
hysterical and i'm so happy and i'm
excited to see her her work me too and
so it's on paramount plus which is so
interesting because i thought casey was
an amazon prime video girl you know with
the whole christmas special mountain
plus yeah is it out yet september 10th
oh my god really so she's like really
making a movie yes
i'm so confused me too sure i'll watch
it yeah she really does have like an
amazing eye her christmas special was so
gorgeous and that was totally like her
pov like it was like a kaleidoscope of
casey masquerade so i trust her yeah no
i i totally agree okay are you ready to
switch gears a little bit to some new
couple news
channing tatum and zoe kravitz have been
spotted around nyc on another one of his
bicycles how weird is this like so
random but like they've been
popping up a lot this week just like i
guess it's like you know when you go out
with someone once and you just like
can't stop seeing them and you just want
to see him every day and ride his
bicycle um and they're like having nice
coffee and laughing and just being
pretty fabulous and so at first i was
like
okay and now i'm like oh okay yeah oh
that's literally a tick-tock sound
really oh my god
oh my god
you've got to get on tock jackie like
it's killing me like we are so sympatico
and this is like the one thing we like
you don't know what i'm saying any of
the times okay also i don't know if any
of you who don't have tic tac have
experiences but now when people send me
tick tocks over text i can't even watch
them in safari anymore it they've
changed
it's like a little bar and i can only
open it by downloading the app so they
totally [ __ ] me they [ __ ] you like
literally yesterday i made the best tic
tac reference and it was just like slid
it in on the show and you didn't even
know you know it was good i uh liked the
beat like you don't even know what i'm
saying and it's so frustrating here's
the thing
like
the thing is the thing is i deleted tick
tock a while ago
and now it's like i already feel like i
spend too much time on my phone if i
download tik tok that's adding at least
two hours of screen time to my average
screen time it's so worth it though it's
not it's it's just like
i think it's
healthiest for me to not be on tick tock
we'll reevaluate okay i just it would be
so much screen time it's so exciting and
sometimes i'm on my phone like and i
feel like i'm using my phone too much
and i have nothing to even do so i'm
like put it down [ __ ] but if i had
something to do like i wouldn't put it
down yeah but like you're the queen like
sending around reels and i just want to
let you know like for our brand you
can't be doing that who do i send reels
to me you literally sent me like three
yesterday what are you referring to
i only send reels when it's like cute
cavaliers
you send plenty of reels i just want to
let you know
it doesn't feel like that to me um what
was the story oh jenny so i just have to
say zoey i know that you were like a
really big fan of him and jesse jesse j
and i agree and so like while i am
mourning this couple
and i do think that this couple's super
cute
i kind of feel like zoey kravitz is like
a little too good for him yeah no she is
like he's like turning into a loser
first of all he's not to make this about
age he's 41 like which i didn't know and
she's 32.
that's not no no it's but like he's like
and he's just like so
like corny
like the magic mike and like he's like
tacky
and she's like cheesy cheesy yes
but i love him and she is grace magellan
she is like the coolest girl in the
world yeah but you know
that but that's also kind of what makes
this cute the fact that like i don't
know what he usually dresses like in his
personal life but he's clearly like
trying to be cool to be cool it's like
extremely sweet
and so that's why at first i was like oh
no but now i'm like oh no i don't know
i'm just feeling like my perception of
channing tatum is
constantly evolving and like i really
like to live in a space where channing
tatum is still like 19 and she's the man
and like that's my nothing but respect
for my channing tatum yeah um but then
he moved into this like step up
like jenna dwan phase and he was totally
irrelevant to me like i never watched
those movies and like i just find i
found his dancing to be cringy like i
did i'm sorry and then they were like
the dancing couple and it was just like
i i didn't really associate with them at
all and then when they broke up i'm like
oh hot man's on the market and like the
jesse j of it all really was like a
wonderful pairing and now i just feel
like he's kind of social climbing his
way like back to the top because he is
like irrelevant
yeah but he's also really successful
like think like
think of like 21 drum street and 22. you
know yeah like he's also really funny
and so i could just see him like at
thanksgiving with zoe and jason mamoa
and mama and mama and lenny and like i
really like that for him like he
deserves happiness too yeah and like
jenna dwan has moved on in every way
yeah and so like i'm i'm happy to see i
don't think he's social climbing because
i don't think
i don't think that would work for him if
this were not genuine but it could i
think there's a genuine connection like
he's making her laugh no me too i just
feel like
come on zoe like we can do better no but
like the heart wants what it wants
and the heart wants magic mind and also
like i i just don't feel like chatting
tatum should have to be such a hard to
sell for us like he's
at one point of his life like a
heartthrob yeah no that's true that's
true he does have a lot of success so
it's not like so maybe he's not where he
was but like you know he's he's got ass
it's just crazy because like for me like
zoe kravitz is one like one of if not
the most eligible women in hollywood
like she's so cool her family's so cool
she's stunning she's like on every
magazine like
and like
i don't know it just it's an interesting
pairing that's what else it is and i
officially
ship wow it doesn't take a lot for you
no it doesn't i just i love to see you
know love and i love i
i just like to see new couples i just
like to say i'm just being negative like
i do like them i just think it's
interesting yeah
no i'm not building a ship not yet okay
i'm gonna build like a little ship you
know i don't know this is a story
because it's like i feel like no one
cares but irina shaik and kanye like
broke up officially oh i i didn't like i
thought that already happened i thought
that already happened too but our next
story is about kanye so revealing
drake's address
no it's about him rebuilding his
childhood home for the donda listening
party
the rapper is rebuilding his childhood
home in the middle of chicago soldier
field where he'll be playing his
forthcoming album on thursday according
to online photos snap from inside
stadium
he wiped his entire account over the
weekend on instagram and began uploading
photos having only to do with donda and
kicked off with a photo of the home he
once shared with his beloved late mother
who the album is named after that's
really cute really cute so
we're
moving towards a donda release date well
i guess we're doing another donda
listening party at a different stadium i
wonder if he'll sleep there as well yeah
and
then who knows
who knows well the other thing i wanted
to say was like so there's been this
like weird drake kanye fight for a while
um but connie posted on instagram like a
a map of a
it's like you know how you can look
through your phone and see where you
took a photo yeah and he had a photo of
him playing basketball at drake's house
and it's like the map literally showing
people where drake's house is and
everyone's like you leaked his address
but
celebrity addresses like our
public information so i don't know if
it's like that big of a deal i don't
know if drake has to move but everyone's
now wondering if like now this is a
reignited feud because they've been
pretty quiet for a while got it but then
i saw something that was like drake
laughing drake laughing because it
wasn't even his address or something
well he just put up an instagram story
in response to it like he was in the
back of like a rolls royce just like
laughing into his camera he did look
like a freak um i hate when people do
that like
um so i don't know like what that means
i didn't get like a translation so
either he's like okay with it or like
he's oh crazy kanye again i don't know
yeah i i don't know either but all it
just like makes me think about is the
fact that like kiki yeah do you love me
how you writing say you never ever leave
on beside me
and what was so crazy is like the whole
world was singing that song just like
kiki no one was thinking anything i
wasn't singing anything and then like
the rumors started circulating that like
kiki's about kim no and then kanye made
that video like drake how would you feel
if i made a song riri do you love me and
i was like oh my god this is about geeks
this is about angels and geeks like
which is crazy but is it i don't know i
don't know
i don't know
and then there was like a song lyrics
right out like making two right and
that's how you got from drake's house to
connie's house and i'm to kim's house in
hollywood hills yeah so like that was
just that sort of lives in my mind
rent-free me too and there's so much
ambiguity like about this feud there are
certain feuds like i could tell you you
know the origin and this is just i feel
like a deep rooted it also has to do
with the fact that like drake
had a baby and like nobody knew about it
and kanye told everyone some [ __ ] like
that yeah there's a lot of i think
there's a lot we don't know so we can
history so without all the facts i just
can't and you know how much it pains us
to talk about things when we don't have
full context here at the morning toes so
it really really does so it's actually a
policy of ours we won't do it are you
ready for our next story which is a
little health news a little health news
perfectly brought to you by chirp yes a
brand dedicated to helping the world
feel good so they can do more of the
stuff that they love they're all about
feel good do more chirp is creating
simple innovative and effective pain
relief and prevention solutions and they
started with a revolutionary wheel for
back pain but they're just getting
started if you have back pain you guys
know like in covid i became like a
grandmother and i developed back
problems like i throw my back out i have
back spasms and it's just it's the worst
thing it's so
painfully like debilitating you really
can't do anything and there's really
never been a brand that's like fully
dedicated to helping people out with
their back pain until chirp
they prevent millions of americans from
they back pain prevents millions of
americans from feeling at their best and
when they don't feel their best they're
limited to what they can do but chirp
can help fix that with their
patent-pending spinal canal and three
different pressure options to choose
from chirp will help your back feel
better so you can be back to doing what
you love in no time i actually have the
uh spinal canal um
product and it's crazy
first of all i don't really feel like i
have any or i know of any brands that
are fully committed to like
attacking back pain and chirp is just
that and their products they feel
like it's crazy like if you have back
pain i really feel like you'll enjoy it
yeah we have one here at the studio and
then we also have them in our individual
homes because we're just always you know
complaining about our pain but also
really alleviates it does and the thing
that i like is like i have a very low
tolerance for like pressure or pain so
they come with um different pressure
sizes gentle medium and deep i of course
went with the gentle but like ben can do
the deep one um which i really like so
the spinal canal comforts your spine as
the wheel gives your back a unique
four-way stretch and each of the wheels
can hold up to 500 pounds and they can
be nestled together for easy travel to
take with you wherever you go it's
really a game changing product and if
you want to check it out get 10 off the
site use code toast go chirp.com
is the website and code is toast for 10
off site wide go chirp.com promo code
toast thank you claudia our next story
is a little health news apparently
eating one hot dog takes 30 minutes off
of your life a study suggests you're
kidding researchers released a
nutritional index this week aiming to
inform guidelines and help americans
achieve healthier and more environmental
environmentally stable diets the index
ranged foods by minutes gained or lost
off healthy life per serving with
processed meats and sugary drinks among
the biggest offenders what's a sugary
drink not like a diet coke right a soda
i'm sure
there's no sugar in diet coke no no
right but there's fake sugar which i'm
sure poses a different issue yeah
aspartame yeah findings included over
5000 foods in the u.s diet classified by
health burden and environmental impacts
we use the results to inform marginal
dietary substitutions which are
realistic and feasible we find that
small targeted food level substitutions
can achieve compelling nutritional
benefits and environmental impact
reductions i just want to say
sugary drinks hot dogs burgers and
breakfast sandwiches were linked with
the most minutes of healthy life lost
okay i just want to say that whereas
fruit
non-starchy and mixed vegetables ready
to eat cereals and cooked grains were
associated with the largest gains cereal
for every hot dog you eat you have a
piece of fruit you balance out your
lifespan i just want to say like finally
being a picky eater works my benefit
i've never eaten a hot dog in my life
never even taken a bite of one oh you've
missed out they're disgusting looking
i'll have a burger maybe once a year
really like i don't really have a lot of
burgers never had a breakfast sandwich
in my life yeah never and what was the
other one the other one was
sugary drinks
okay they got me there but like what's
considered a sugary drink like i like
gatorade
is that sugary yeah for sure but you
don't like it's not like that's part of
your
daily routine
no no not part of my daily routine but
like drinking diet coke and diet pepsi
is they didn't specify on diet i don't
think that has to do with sugary drinks
because it's technically zero sugar so
basically what you're saying
is that i live a healthy lifestyle
according to this
study thank you that you do
also foods like salted peanuts baked
salmon and rice with beans were also a
site associated with gains between 10
and 15 minutes of life literally i have
salmon and rice for every meal oh my god
wait
this is crazy like i am the healthiest
person alive
i'm going to live forever oh my god stop
knock on wood
no wait i'm shook yeah salmon and rice i
mean and i had chili last night i'm
sorry i forgot to bring it to you i
forgot
ben made a [ __ ] heavenly ass chili
but you know what that's what i'm having
for lunch how dare you how do you eat
chili i heat it up and then i add a
little cheese sour cream
but i'm saying you just put chili on the
spoon like you don't have rice i put
chili on the spoon with a little sour
cream and cheese yeah i eat it with
tostitos yeah like a dip i'm sure it's
literally like 30 times worse for you
eating a chili or even like taco meat on
a on a tostito like a crunchy scoop
actually i prefer the bite size but you
know what i'm saying is so heavenly like
we said healthiest person
no i just want to say like for all the
people who like look down on me for my
eating habits
jokes on you
[ __ ] because this
what organization was this this was um
the michigan
the michiganites
approve of my lifestyle the university
of michigan school of public health
thank you you of msph
yeah but you know what this really
doesn't account for like getting hit by
a car
and no of course not uh like so i'm sure
that's why all these things are so
irrelevant they're so irrelevant and you
know what
i have to say does it account for like
terminal illnesses no no it's just like
it i think in an ideal world if a person
never left the house
and like was in an incubator like yes
yes
i think they're just trying to get
people to understand like the
varying effects
i will say a hot dog is worth the 35
minutes i was gonna say now that you
know this information like will you
think twice before picking up a hot dog
i know you love hot dogs no no for every
hot dog i have i'll have a piece of
fruit and you hate fruit and i've been
getting more into fruit recently really
i haven't because of pritikin like they
are so fruit-tastic they're fruity so it
made me have like a new appreciation for
fruit and especially in the summer i've
been having some oranges and they're
quite delectable i just have to say like
fruit in the summer when i was in the
hamptons i was sitting outside eating
cherries and i really thought like i
could go on a diet like it's so
i don't know the right word is like
refreshing it's so refreshing it's like
it's like eating
water almost like it's so hydrating you
just get these like bursts of flavor and
when i was in florida like we would
order fruit plate and they have the best
freshest produce in florida and like
it was heavenly no i honestly think that
like fruit should exclusively be eaten
on vacation or
in the summer yeah so i i'm definitely
changing my ways and my my thoughts and
feelings about fruit i've been enjoying
an apple here and there an apple a day
keeps the doctor away so you want to
keep dr faceman nice and close
yeah yeah so i don't eat any apples no
but so if i want a hot dog i'm going to
pair it with rice and beans
fruit and cereal yum
i've actually really been getting into
cereal it's a great loophole i know what
you think considers a bowl of cereal a
snack or a meal i think most people
consider it a meal i think that's insane
like
it's a snack well i guess like if it's
part of a balanced breakfast then you
also have like a banana oj yeah so if
you're just eliminating those items and
you're just having that
maybe it's a snack i think it's how much
cereal you put in the bowl and if you
drink the milk like if i just want to
say like if you drink your milk out of
the cereal bowl please never in your
life address me or look me in the eyes
because you and i
have beef
you have processed beef and take 35
minutes out of your life and if i
literally was sitting at
the dining room table with ben and he
was we were eating cereal and he started
to slurp his bowl
you would get up pack your bags and go
yeah
so
just wanted to put that out there not to
be dramatic or anything
are you ready for a fifth and final
story
no but but you're about to be now i am
it's the final story
do
do
[Music]
[ __ ] stunning wow you never curse
really i feel like i cursed say it again
[ __ ] stunning no you only curse when
you're like having a cleveland day which
i was on the verge of having here today
honestly i can't even differentiate
cleveland days from non-cleveland days
because every day for the last year and
a half has been a cleveland day or it
has cleveland-like elements
no that would make it a positive
day
remember when new york and cleveland
were having beef on the internet were
they yeah like
um yes the new york um like the official
new york account for like the mayor or
like the government or something posted
like a bad day in new york is better
than a great day in cleveland like
that's actually not true at all that's
actually not true have you been to
cleveland and then like delightful
cleveland came back strong good and it
was just a really crazy time did you see
that that monstrous animal cuomo left
his dog behind because he officially
resigned yeah i was gonna say today we
have a new governor today oh yeah i know
nothing about her gotta look it's her
right yeah
got it gotta research yeah i don't know
anything about her either i just know
she's not cuomo and so that's really
exciting
but seriously justice for the dog like
what happened jess is for the dog
justice for the dogs uh as if like
cuomo's like public approval rating
couldn't go down more like the dogs
really like
sick disgusting twisted you also saw
that story i sent you about the dogs in
australia
i really don't want to talk about it
okay but if you guys don't know what i'm
talking about just google australia
dogs trigger alert
it's not been a good week for the dogs
trigger warning seriously it's a really
[ __ ] sad like horrible horrific story
so but i won't talk about it okay are
you ready for our fifth and final story
oh
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
i love that [ __ ]
okay
finally for the [ __ ] final
story jesus christ
instagram is retiring the swipe up
instead we will have link stickers
starting august 30th the swipe up will
be no more
instagram is planning to retire the
feature which allows people to visit
external websites by swiping up
instead you will get a swipe up i'm
sorry a link click sticker just like you
know a white box yeah when you're like
shopping you can like tap the product
they'll be tappable stickers and stories
that take people to external websites
they think it'll you know streamline the
creative process and more so which i
read at the bottom of the article it's
like when you have a swipe up on your
story people can't respond to it okay so
so the stickers would solve that i think
but like
i mean i have my responses off
regardless and
i just i don't think every story
requires a response no so that's the
thing so a lot of people here are like
this is literally an update nobody
[ __ ] asks for like there's so many
other things we want on instagram if
it's not broke like why are we fixing it
it seems so random and i guess like the
only the only issue people have with the
swipe ups is that usually if you want to
respond to someone's messages you
literally swipe up and the message thing
comes up but if there's a link there's
no way to do that and i just feel like
we could have solved this very very
small irrelevant problem that doesn't
really affect a lot of people in a
different way like i think that the
swipe ups are great i don't know if this
button i've been like reading like what
people think about it like their
reactions on social media and people
either think it's gonna like skyrocket
engagement or completely deplete it and
a lot of people's businesses like rely
on those swipe up links yeah i honestly
don't think it will like make that much
of a difference and i'm sure eventually
it'll be like oh i can't believe we ever
said swipe up yes but it's just crazy
how like swipe up has become such a part
of the jargon so if you're making a
video now and you still have and you
have and you don't have swipe ups but
you have the sticker what are you going
to say like tap through or people are
probably still going to say swipe up
people are probably still going to say
swipe up for a while like yeah but it's
just going to be like tap the link tap
the link in my story i like hate that
yeah swipe up was just like fun and
funny and cute yeah
so end of an era for swipe ups and it
just seems like so random like i just
feel like every day we come on here and
we talk about like features on instagram
that we wish we were better like we're
always talking about that and then they
just come out with this like what yeah
like nobody was complaining about this
whatsoever no i'm sure it's like for
their internal purposes of like
engagement and keeping people addicted
to their app like yeah there's something
beneficial here but instagram like
really is slowly driving away like
creators like because i know a lot of
creators who are like younger
are just like getting
growing so much faster on like tick tock
and making so much more money from the
creator fund and
instagram announced like a couple weeks
ago that they were like dedicating a
billion dollars to creator funds like
paying creators but it's not the same
way that like tick tock and youtube does
it it's not through ads it's like
go live and get a badge it's like a game
it's like silly like they're really not
investing in creators and i just feel
like a lot of the young people who want
to become like famous on instagram
they're going to start going to other
platforms
we shall see
we'll see what the youths are up to also
before i get into the bathroom paradise
recap i wanted to just talk about
because i watched nine perfect strangers
oh but i haven't seen it yet and i
actually will watch it okay
there's only the first three episodes
out okay i just want to say i am so glad
i didn't read the book
because i'm enjoying the show and i
usually don't enjoy both and i people
were like you should read it for your
wellness retreat i'm so [ __ ] glad
that i didn't because obviously like
this wellness retreat and nine perfect
strangers it's spooky and like extremely
nefarious and questionable and it would
have made me so
nervous to already go like to retreat by
myself where i didn't know what to
expect and like in the
in the show like they take the the
people's blood when they get there
but they did that at my retreat too and
like i it was normal because they needed
to like measure your health levels i'm
dead we like we got blood work all the
time it's actually like you know to see
your cholesterol in your blood right now
it was like and so if i had read the
book and then i saw they were taking my
blood i would have been like i would
have left totally so i'm really enjoying
it you should watch it it's really good
it's a good cast and
it's good okay so tell me what happened
on bathroom paradise and i just want to
say like i think that we should
do dear toasters tomorrow because we're
doing like so well with what's going on
there was crazy construction noises like
right before we started we were nervous
and i just want to push our luck i feel
like you tell me background paradise and
then we'll solve
tomorrow's problem tomorrow i agree okay
okay bachelor in paradise so like i said
like there are some really strong
couples demi came down the stairs
yesterday and uh she took brendan on a
date brendan had been vibing with
natasha like a lot and so natasha was
kind of
freaking out while he was on the date
like just because like demi like came in
like really hot and like you know
energetic and
i'm gonna steal your man to everyone and
so she was nervous but then also while
brendan was gone there started like this
rumor going around about him that like
he had been dating piper before she's
not on the show yet you know i actually
heard that so
natasha like knows brendan's on the
stage oh and he's dating piper like kind
of waiting for her to come i guess
and everyone's like brendan's a player
brendan's a player but we haven't heard
anything from brendan brendan goes on
his date with demi i think they have a
really good time
and then like she wants to you know talk
about like where things are going to go
and he's sort of like i want to keep my
options open like you know this isn't it
for me pretty much and she was like so
angry and like embarrassed and she felt
rejected and she was like throwing a
temper tantrum the whole rest of the
episode it was a really bad look i i
don't know anyone who like came off the
episode like feeling favorably more
favorably towards them than they did the
last time they saw her on the show
um it's a little like
i think
even weird that she's in paradise i
think it is too what's really weird
about this season is like because it's
matt's girls are like the new girls and
they're like but peter's girls are also
this is also their parents we skipped a
year but like to when you're watching
the show peter's girls are just
completely overlooked and it's like
so so for colton's girl to show up it's
just like oh no and so now i'm like even
extra worried for becca kufrin to come
like there is nobody room for her
there's no room for her there's no one
there's no room for anyone before peter
season like i i swear because like
that's how much like this like this this
turnover nation like they just want like
what's hot
the the contestants within themselves
they don't want someone's old you know
stale 800 000 followers who are no
longer engaged totally i want your fresh
500k totally
so it's just really interesting and i i
don't think i think demi really um came
off quite terribly last night wow yeah
she was just like throwing a fit the
whole rest of the day and like so upset
with brendan that like he even went on
the date with her like but he went to
explore that's a really frustrating part
of watching these shows is like the
suspense of no not this one like
there's no common sense like everyone's
acting like we're not on an island and
we haven't known each other for four
days but she knows she's just like mad
because she played the whole thing wrong
she came in she wanted to go out with
brandon i guess he's like one of the
hottest guys there and not only is he
into someone else like he's not into you
and he might be into piper and she made
the wrong choice and like that was your
one date and the boys have the roses
this week like you played yourself yeah
so she was just sort of like being crazy
about that but then
brendan eventually comes back and
everybody's talking about brendan but
it's like what does brendan have to say
like we know brendan from tasha's season
like brendan is a pretty good guy what
does brendan have to say and he said
like he had dated pipers before the show
but out of like everyone and even with
his date with demi like he's feeling
natasha the most oh my god i really love
him so like he didn't lie and like that
was true and i also feel like every
single person there
was like talking before the show or even
dating before the show because the way
that they're all so connected already
it's like we missed the falling in love
part okay i completely agree and i feel
like back in the day when we used to
watch bathroom houses for joe and
samantha yes it was like the worst thing
you could do and now just like with
social media and like how bachelor
like the producers they're always like
bringing people together like people are
always doing events and then they're
going on like there's just so many
opportunities that you would meet
someone who would be on paradise so now
it doesn't seem like a big deal at all
but yes joe and samantha like they want
to make a big deal that like he was
talking to piper but it's like i could i
feel as though some of these couples
you're you were talking before too and
you just got lucky that you're all first
week people yeah because everybody had
the person that they were already like
going for
so brendan and natasha are interested so
you're saying it feels like
predetermined almost yeah like all these
conversations already happened and like
there's no room like i don't know it's
just yeah it feels like everyone's been
talking for now two years like they know
exactly what they want like there is no
like i'm going to talk to him and then
him and i don't know who i like more
like it's just like i like him yeah
we're getting engaged what happened with
grocery store joe and serena oh they
were totally quiet this season this
episode nothing happened he gave her his
rose like they're going strong but next
week someone comes down and takes serene
on a date oh
um
so brendan and natasha are good and i'm
so happy for them and it's all good
there then
i've been and who gives demi a rose just
wait ivan and jesenya went on a
one-on-one they got like the first
official cup like of a couple one-on-one
not like someone coming down with a date
card and like they're oh they're getting
aged like they're everything of the sort
like they were so [ __ ] cute like they
are going all the way i really believe
that and also like based on the previews
i don't know why
i feel like i remember them being
together so
good so cute so there's like a lot of
love happening so far already like
couples that you could really feel like
are getting engaged how's abigail and
so strong or anything from them
like that he gave her the rose kenny and
mari are going so strong
i don't like that couple but okay
he gave her the rose um
everyone who you saw like got that rose
and then victoria p okay she was the
drama well she was the drama on her
season too and she like got away with
actually being like sneaky like but like
so she when she came on her season like
i think i had her picked for my top four
like i thought this girl was going
places like
and it's just been such a fall for
victoria yeah and last night she fell
even it was no different
so basically there's this guy his name
is james he's from kd season i think so
we don't know him but he seems really
cute and nice whatever and he's really
into victoria p and he's made that clear
and she is like
you know
just giving him like enough to want to
get his rose but in her confessionals
she can't remember his name she's like
what's his name
uh jason
over and over and over when she's
talking to the other girl she's like
what's his name
can't remember his name she's literally
saying in her confessionals like that
she just wants a rose and that like
she'll stick with james in order to get
it meanwhile like he's really into her
and then tammy
comes through love tammy tammy comes
through and lets us know that victoria p
has a boyfriend in nashville an aspiring
country singer who she is here just to
like you know
be on the show and then bring cameras
back home to help her boyfriend get
famous
what how does tammy know that tammy i
guess like people know it and
victoria p lives in nashville and kelsey
lives in nashville and tammy goes and
who kelsey our girl oh our girl she
isn't home in iowa anymore no she moved
to nashville
so
the night of the rose ceremony it really
feels like everything's buttoned up
because everybody knows who they're
going to get their roses to except um
james is probably going to give it to
victoria p but they're the least strong
couple because she literally doesn't
know his name and can't [ __ ] stand
him so that leaves kelsey and demi open
to go home kelsey demi victoria queen
oh right serena c
serena she's from matt james the season
you thought she was a mean girl yeah she
was she made a last-ditch effort to go
after tammy's man but like tammy has her
[ __ ] in check like tammy's on lock tap
no tammy is that mock i was so sammy's
man tammy i think his name is aaron and
she just like from the day she got to
the beach she's like i like aaron now
they're like fabulous and then like
serena she went after him and like made
out with him and i was like oh serena is
giving tammy a run for her money
tammy comes back around literally
straddles her man
starts hanging out with him like
while also going to james like this
whole evening she's booked and busy she
has her man on lock and she's also
letting james like
she's she's spitting truth spitting
truths so she tells james about victoria
p and he's like shocked he spent like
the last few days like totally invested
in this girl was gonna give her this
rose and like what's the truth
and tammy says kelsey lives in nashville
too and like she knows this to be true
as well so then kelsey's talking to
james and like she's like feels so bad
to have to like tell him that this is
what's true but like she's a little
she's also like are you okay and i'm
like
rose i'm like rose rose i'm right on top
of that road what about calcium right
so then
james finally goes and talks to victoria
p and he's like they told me this is
this true and she's literally
gaslighting the [ __ ] out of him she's
like you're being so aggressive like
he's literally just sitting there saying
is this true like she really thought she
was doing something i think she realized
quickly she wasn't she's doing nothing
so she like tries to like talk her way
around it for a while talks to other
girls like i thought i love you guys how
like you don't [ __ ] love them so we
already know you're a liar if you're
saying that
and then she leaves she's just like she
can't she leaves and in the car she's
like talking about how like no like you
know just saying like platitudes of
words about how like she's
you know they
this drama blah blah blah at the end she
goes
i don't need to be here to look for
something that i already have at home
oh so she was lying so she admitted it
yeah oh my god what a loser beyond
beyond like that's so embarrassing like
you got caught
i'm crying beyond losery so then james's
rose is the only rose in contention did
you give it to demi and kelsey
you know is being herself and she was
just like you know i would like your
rose like
she was just being like really cute
talking to james and demi is like
watching her being like kelsey's so
desperate blah blah and then demi goes
and has a conversation with james and is
like
you know i want your rose and he's like
i'm what tonight's gonna be a friendship
rose like whoever i give it to and she's
like you only want to be friends and
it's like you literally didn't even know
this guy before two minutes ago and
she's like are we gonna have sex oh and
so
in the rose ceremony
he gave his rose to demi i believe it
was producers who made him do so yeah
because like she you know will cause
drama and everything so kelsey went home
serena c went home queen victoria went
home it was time for queen victoria and
it was time for serena to see but like
yet again like kelsey i feel like she's
this great girl who gets overlooked on
these shows just because she's not like
annoying and thirsty and like can i play
for a chat like yeah but the thing is is
that i really can't watch a show and
honestly i think it has a lot to do with
demi like
first of all she had this like storybook
ending on her time on bachelor in
paradise it was this national story it
was this like finally great moment for
bachelor nation and like i do think that
like
she was i don't know where i heard this
once but it's so funny and it's the best
way to describe it like someone told
demi burnett she was america's
sweetheart and she believed it and like
now she's just like on this i think she
thinks she's too good for all these
people like walking in like oh you don't
want to date me i'm america's sweetheart
like literally she might as well said
that and she has that attitude on social
media too and then i do think a couple
months ago there's like she was knocked
the [ __ ] down with her old tweets which
i do think like was a humbling moment
for her but i just i don't like vibe
with her at all like i was very much on
board for like the demi of it all when
she opened up
on her season and then on bachelor in
paradise about her mom being in prison
and then struggles with her sexuality
and i thought those were all great
conversations to have and now she's just
striking me as annoying beyond and the
way she came in was reminding me of that
time the fergie twins came on yeah in
their second season they did their
bachelor in paradise season where they
skated by like for a whole year because
if you gave one twin a rose you got them
both and they were just like friends
with everyone and then they came back
the next year towards the end and like
we're so disgusting towards everyone
better than every queen like and that
was the energy that demi was giving me
and it's like
is she to this group of people she's
pretty irrelevant and like she's old and
she was like um and i don't even know
the ages comparatively but yeah she's
old news like she had next season right
no she's cold in season so she had her
time
and she had her time she was like asking
brandon like what's your story you're
from tasha season i didn't watch like
sure so how do you know it's from
tasha's season well like
maybe he's like i don't know she's just
too she's
too cool
too cool
to know you and so like now she lives to
another two weeks because next week the
girls have the rose and like
i don't i don't know if i'll be watching
honestly i don't know you really sold it
like i'm hooked because last night's
episode was good
of course like the one i don't watch but
then all these couples like look locked
and loaded and i mean it does look like
tonight and it's interesting because
like there was 10 roses so nine couples
are like
steadfast so it's like whoever comes
down next week whichever girls like turn
their heads were like the ones who were
maybe like not so steadfast but right
we're showing us steadfastness right
right right so like that is interesting
but i also feel like yeah people will go
and make out with other people and try
and find connections but i think they're
going to kind of come back to the people
that they
initially that they initially vibe with
i don't know if we learned to anything
for marcus and lacey it's that nothing
is for certain
no but like marcus and like but that's
still the craziest thing to me that ever
happened on that show like they were in
love got married and then we never heard
from them again and they were never even
really married
yeah no that's not what's so crazy to me
but if you remember the way that they
got together roberto robert grant
oh it was robert graham i think so no i
don't think so i think it was the guy
who dated back at tilly yeah but that
was before becca but i'm pretty sure so
like lacey it was week one lacey was
like lacey and robert
and
marcus really liked lacey and the
producers let him give his rose before
robert
and he gave it to lacey which was like
so [ __ ] random yeah and the rest is
history and they were so cute even
though they didn't work out and he's
married to someone else and so is she i
consider it in what i saw on tv like
that was a love story like
goodbye and they got married at the
next season like and then it turned out
they were never married like i don't
care about what happened after the tv
show yeah i care about what i'm the con
that was a great turn of events yeah
um well i don't know i'm like kind of
feeling like now i want to watch um
i don't know if i'll watch tonight i'll
see where i'm at but
it just sort of felt like
i've seen this show yeah i think i've
seen this film before
and i didn't like the ending
okay i mean i'm feeling really good it's
so quiet should we do your toasters sure
because you never know what tomorrow
will bring no totally but like the
construction outside has really quieted
down all right dear toasters our advice
segment
which is brought to you by pura vida and
a power brand that's all about comfort
fun and living life to the fullest you
could shop now and give back with pura
vita one of the coolest apparel and
accessory brands out there they're
always giving back and it's always been
at the core of what they do pura vita
was started by two california surfers
who went to costa rica and fell in love
with the art and laid-back lifestyle
they began partnering with costa rican
artisans to create beautiful braided
bracelets selling millions each year so
they're known for their beautiful
braided bracelets that are handmade by
artisans and the string bracelets that
are unisex fully adjustable and wax
coated so they're 100 waterproof so if
you have an active lifestyle much like
we do you gotta check it out all their
jewelry is super affordable with
bracelets starting at six dollars and
rings starting at twelve dollars and
it's great if you love to stack rings
because you can buy a bunch and they're
super affordable so you don't have to
shell out a ton of money
they also have buttery soft 100 cotton
t-shirts and hoodies including graphic
t-shirts and crop t-shirts their
colorful fun backpacks include tie-dyed
and leopard print and you get free
stickers with every order plus in
addition to just being fabulous jewelry
bracelets backpacks things that you just
need they're also clothing with a cause
you can shop their charity collections
and five percent of your purchase price
is given back to charities that support
things like ocean and land conservation
they've donated over 3.5 million dollars
to charity and they also have
hassle-free returns on all their
clothing so keep an eye out for their
fall clothing and jewelry line that are
launching this august make sure to get
it and if you want a code piravida looks
good and it does good so get to to get
twenty percent off your pura vita order
text toast to three eight eight one
seven that's t-o-e-s-t to three eight
eight one seven to get twenty percent
off at pura vita terms apply available
at purevitabracelets.com terms again
that's toast text it to 38817
all right dear toasters our advice
segment where if you're ever feeling
like you need some advice from two of
your favorite gals email us to your
toasters gmail.com and we will keep you
anonymous don't worry
dear claudia and jackie first and
foremost i've always loved tuning into
the toast but something about these
episodes in 2020 2021 lately have me in
stitches laughing thank you
my write-in isn't asking for advice but
absolutely feels like something you guys
would love to unpack and maybe even help
solve a mystery
i was inspired by the tel aviv poop
coverage to tell you this if you guys
remember we reported that
in
cities like tel aviv they're testing
dna samples like if you leave your poop
on the street from your dog from your
dog not from you they'll send you a
ticket okay
i went to high school in new jersey and
our animal print themed homecoming dance
in 2011 someone pooped on the dance
floor
my school didn't have a proper
auditorium we had a convertible
cafeteria auditorium the cafetorium as
we called it without disclosing the name
of the school or any other alumni
watching or listening to this episode
they will know the history
from this of the story from these
details we were all on the
makeshift dance floor having a grand old
time and the set the set
and all of a sudden we had to actually
evacuate the dance floor
evacuate the dancer
she had to evacuate the dance floor
and have a janitor come clean up the
poop on the floor it wasn't diarrhea or
anything that would have made you think
someone was sick or lost control but
it's a mystery that plagues our hometown
and people still discuss it i wish we
could have a dna test that that poop do
you think it was a girl in a dress or a
guy who got it out of his pants
can you offer a reward to anyone who can
tell the truth about this sincerely who
pooped on the floor 10 years ago well
see i didn't really understand why you
were writing in until this moment new
jersey we have a very big tri-state area
audience and i wasn't playing we were
the biggest podcast in new jersey but
they haven't run that report since 2018.
we're we're still technically the
biggest podcasting reigning reigning
queens of new jersey so i just i
appreciate you putting this out there
because there's nothing obviously we can
do to solve it except use our platform
for good and not evil so if you went to
this high school and you obviously know
this ill-fated story of the duty on the
floor and you know who did it i have to
imagine it was a girl in a dress neither
i don't think it was a girl in a dress
and i don't think it was through a boy's
pant legs i think a boy pulled his pants
down and shot on the floor you know what
actually i'm thinking now someone would
have seen that
i feel like these kids were getting hot
and heavy i feel like it was a prank or
yeah someone pooped elsewhere brought it
in or it was dog poop that they like put
in a bag and dropped on the floor yeah i
agree it's a prank for sure yeah
okay let's move on hello i'm in a pickle
and i'm hoping you ladies can help i got
engaged a few weeks ago finally and my
boyfriend did a great job with securing
a photographer to take photos of the
proposal here's the issue we got the
photos back and they are incredibly
disappointing they look like my 60 year
old mother took them on an iphone 5.
they are incredibly zoomed in even
though the background was a very
beautiful beach and there was a railing
fence blocking the big down on the knee
moment there also aren't any photos of
the setup and the decor the flowers the
photos of us i'm not sure if this person
had ever photographed a proposal before
but i can't believe we have no postable
photos from this i'm so upset but i also
feel like i can't let my fiance know i'm
disappointed because i know he did his
best finding a photographer and planning
it all attached is the photo
it's not good any thoughts should i
reach out to the photographer and ask if
she has any more photos i'm worried my
fiance will notice i'm not posting the
photos or displaying them in our house
help okay i have a few things i want to
say okay
i see this photo we can't post it on
instagram because i don't want it's not
great
i feel like you could find an editor to
remove that railing first of all not
really second of all it is worth noting
that like a lot of the pictures you see
of other people's proposals on social
media
are reenacted so if you wanted to go
back down there with another
photographer even just like your iphone
and like your friend who's tech savvy
wear the same outfits and like get a
bottle of champagne
you could redo it and of course it's
worth reaching out to the woman or man
and asking if they have more photos just
like can you send all of the you know
the drafts yeah this is really really
frustrating at first i was like okay the
photos aren't great but like you know
what i don't like i thought i had good
photos now i look back on them i'm like
that's a big leg
[Laughter]
so but now after like the way that
you're describing it like i would be so
incredibly frustrated definitely ask the
photographer for every single picture
that she took in there you should be
able to find one i don't think you need
to go and reenact the pictures if you
want to have an engagement shoot so that
you have more pictures you should go and
do that because like they did capture
like the moment of surprise and what's
the point in paying for a high-class
photographer you're getting blurry
really so [ __ ] pissed me too oh my
god oh my god i i think i would even
like just call and like be a little
rude and and honest because right you're
on the water where's the beach where's
the sun no no that's so horrible like
don't like go no
congratulations that's really all that
matters you got engaged i know but like
and you look so happy it really bothers
me it's very bothersome ask for more
photos
do the most with what find the best one
edit some stuff out add a filter jackie
overload
yeah um and do an engagement shoot you
can get you can reenact
engagement shoots are great because you
wear white and you have nice pictures
for your wedding website and whatever
other assets but then you can also turn
put this dress back on go down to the
beach and get a fake performance before
no no need to know it's fake take your
engagement pictures there and be totally
dolled up by the way my engagement
photos are at the same place i got
engaged and we did a fake proposal yeah
cause it's just good to have more picks
it is good to have more picks this is
frustrating but not the end of the world
so like you know find something that you
like get it up and then move on to the
next phase of the engagement process
don't work on this don't get it all for
climbed yeah all right third and final
one hey jackie and claudia huge fan over
here can't believe i finally have
something to write in about after
listening to y'all dole out amazing
advice for months i'm recently dating a
new guy and he's the sweetest we hit it
off as soon as we met and have been
hanging out casually dating for two-ish
months
flashback to our first date he chose the
restaurant it was great but long story
short when the bill came he didn't even
offer to pay
after it's out there for a minute i
suggest we split it and he didn't object
i didn't really mind at all
at the time but after thinking about it
i'm a little peeved that he picked the
restaurant something more upscale than i
would have chosen for the first date and
then didn't even offer to cover the bill
now fast forward to us going out more
regularly going to bars with friends and
ordering takeout if he covers anything
i'll always receive a venmo request to
split or if we're at a bar he'll say
i'll get this round and you can grab the
next i really like this guy and i don't
see stan this standing in the way of
pursuing something more serious but i'm
am i wrong for thinking it's weird or is
this completely normal my friends are
kind of split is it old-fashioned to me
to think that when you're dating someone
new that they would want to cover the
little things like drinks or even the
first date
i'm adding in here that i know
we can never know another person's
financial situation but i'm 100 sure he
makes more money than me and i also know
that i can pay for my own things but it
also feels good to have someone offer to
buy drinks or little things here and
there i would love an honest opinion
from you guys about how to handle this
or if i should just leave it be any
words of wisdom would be appreciated i
just want to say when you were not here
i did your toasters with
tyler cameron
and we had a similar prompt and i just
want you to know how offended he was he
was like i will pay for everything until
we're 97. it's like not even a dating
phase so it's a guy thing and a girl
thing because i'm i'm not okay with this
okay i'm not okay with this
i just want to say like
the
there are people who would be fine with
this like it's really a personal
preference so you're asking our personal
preference yes and we are strong
independent business women who want
other men to pay for arthritis who like
to be taken care of and treated
sometimes especially at the beginning of
a relationship and it's not about how
much money he does or doesn't make if
he's taking you on a first date
take you to mcdonald's if if he can't
swing the upscale restaurant
with tyler
it's not about rich or poor it's about
being cheap yeah now you could be ver
you could be hella poor and incredibly
generous and you can be very rich and
cheap as [ __ ] it's not about money no
it's not about money and if whatever
half the bill was at the upscale
restaurant he could have spent that at a
different restaurant so like for him to
choose an upsell restaurant and then not
like that is just
a behavior that i find offensive
personally and then also to like venmo
your partner for things that are like
not you know like we're splitting the
groceries today and we're you got the
toilet paper household items like drinks
at the bar like [ __ ] treat you like
you deserve it i'm sorry i know it's
like old-fashioned i guess but like some
things you know it wouldn't it would be
it wouldn't kill us it wouldn't kill us
to uphold you no i just want i
completely agree with you i'm a
progressive woman but i believe in
chivalry and i'm sorry like
i don't think women should pay for stuff
like i'm sorry especially at the
beginning of the relationship eventually
you get to a point where it's like equal
partners
i know what you make you know what i
make so like i'm not you know it is what
it is but in the beginning like you're
being courted yeah
and i'm sorry i'm sure some people are
not gonna agree but that's fine that's
fine uh you should date that guy yeah
right exactly there there's a pot for
every couple but it's like if that if
that bill comes and like he doesn't pick
it up and that like
gives you a pit a little bit then like
then that's a problem and it's okay if
you're that's a problem not with you but
like then maybe you guys are financially
incompatible no and maybe you're now
identifying like
that you want a guy who courts you in
the beginning like maybe you didn't know
that because it always happened then
it's like you oh hypothetically yes but
i don't know i just feel like you
shouldn't be ashamed of the fact that
you want to be courted i think it's very
natural and i think like in our culture
because we're we are striving for
equality this is like a loophole like
i'm striving for equality too but like
not on the first date no and also i just
think like as women like we need to hold
men to a higher standard i agreed the
bar is so the bar is so low and i think
if we all band together and we don't pee
on the toilet seat and we do insist that
men pay especially at the beginning of a
relationship like that's the bare
minimum like then we're helping all
women because then the next girl doesn't
have to sit there with the check in
between the table being like the [ __ ] do
i do with this totally when you were on
your first date with zach did you like
make the move like
you know what i don't think i did that i
did
i don't remember it's so long ago i know
well i wore score and seven years ago i
remember it's like a thing and it's like
you don't want to be like a girl who's
like expecting it so you want to be nice
and be like oh do you want to split but
ideally the person says no
and then
yeah i think that sometimes you want to
be the person that's expecting it
say that again i'd like you just said
like you you lean like you lean for the
wallet just to like not pretend like
you're not expecting it but like
that if that's your expectation that the
man pays for the first date then don't
lean for your wallet no i guess but like
you just don't want to be like a coza i
don't know no like you asked me out
totally even though i like begged you
too you chose this restaurant yeah yeah
i think i chose it no for sure for sure
like you're
yeah yeah yeah
i guess that is conflicting because i'm
i'm of the mindset but you should like
pretend to reach for your wallet but of
course the guy's gonna say no now that i
i talk like such a big game
sure i'm sure i paid for my first date
no kidding
um i'm sure that i did like pretend i'm
sure but you know what now that like in
thinking back
i just think you need to like stand firm
in the things that are important to you
and like if it were today and i was
going on a first date i would not reach
for my wallet yeah
i also i'm just like so curious how this
goes in homosexual relationships like i
think that actually is a really
interesting conversation we should all
come to the card come to the table and
show all of our cards like what are the
rules yeah but but there are no rules
because everybody's different everybody
except expects different things that's
true hetero relationships or homosexual
relationships so like
you have you know why i said homosexual
i sound like a nine-year-old gay so you
have to just
homosexual like hitters what the [ __ ]
is that a textbook
you have to just like you you know do
what's comfortable do what's comfortable
for you so i just but i do feel like i
don't like this like then mo
and it's cause it's making you feel
weird if you didn't care great that's
what you care about but like you feel
weird about it so like
run with that like lean into your
feelings you're entitled to feel how you
feel yeah
i agree but it's a thing like it is a
thing it's a thing but also sometimes
like you maybe just like share your
expectations and maybe you'll be like oh
i didn't know maybe my last girlfriend
insisted we go dutch right maybe i don't
want to offend your female intelligence
right or whatever so like at least give
him the chance of being like you know
it would be nice to be taken care of
sometimes you know
stop answering the venmo request yeah
block him if he starts like following up
notifications yeah then it's time to
yeah but i think first if it bothers you
but you really like this guy
try saying something no i feel like you
should try just like
not responding to the venmos anymore not
offering hey can you go get us a drink i
know but you know the thing about
relationships is communication okay but
they're only two months in they don't
have to communicate yet okay but
you could try claudia's way first and if
still like you're getting
re-notified you will know what this
guy's deal is if you don't respond to
one venmo request and see if he'll send
you a follow-up
yeah you will know then he's not doing
it for his duchess he's doing it because
he's cheap
yeah
yeah
there's nothing worse than a person
who's cheap
and that's different
than not how much money you have yes
i agreed
so that's that on that that was dear
toasters thank you so much to everyone
who wrote in dear toasters at gmail.com
if you want to write in and also dear
toasters at gmail.com if we have given
you some sage advice and you used it or
you didn't use it we want to hear what
happened we'd like a follow-up email so
do that follow up with us
yes please do we shall see you tomorrow
for hump day hopefully we'll get some do
brew or crew and enjoy it thank you guys
so much we'll send you the morning toast
the longest episode of all time thank
you so much for listening to the morning
test monday morning show where we
deliver the fast life stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please definitely subscribe give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and we're
podcasts can be found at spotify itunes
stitch or public radio i already have
boxes all the places webbings and
podcasts finesse someone chose let's
leave a five-star review about a
beautiful setting and smart we are and
if you're still here please leave a hot
dog emoji on our most recent instagram
account because like
hot dogs are good for you yeah and don't
let the cdc that's where hot dogs live
your life it just we will be 35 minutes
shorter